[Music]
and save the internet news submitted by
Billy Bob Joe hey who'd I want that one
on the screen so I'm just gonna munted I
just started joining you guys it looks
like your arm is fighting the other arm
net neutrality is being threatened again
and will be voted on in less than DOS
weeks
I'm glad we're talking about this [ __ ]
cuz we need to talk about [ __ ] like this
is so important that day yeah what is
net neutrality it has to do with tuna
fishing and okay so before I get into
this all the reviewers I encourage you
guys to do your own research on this
topic because this is a very complicated
issue I've been reading it like reading
about it this whole week and some and
it's gonna be really easy for you to
probably like miss some points because
it's a [ __ ] ton of material very
complicated just so you guys know but
the breakdown is breakdown so net
neutrality would the definition of it is
the principle that Internet service
providers aka
ISPs should enable access to all content
and applications regardless of the
source and without favoring or blocking
particular products or websites so
that's what net neutrality is I see so
the FCC has recently announced plans to
dismantle net neutrality so between 2005
and 2012 there have been five failed
attempts at passing a bill like this
right but then finally in 2014 President
Obama recommended the FCC to reclassify
broadband internet service as a
telecommunications service which
basically makes it a utility the same as
electricity or water and so the SEC
agreed and then by the June by June of
2015 this rule went into effect and it
classified broadband as title 2
Communication Service which then allows
heavy heavier regulations than its
previous title 1 classification so
earlier this year the new
reappointed FCC chairman named Ajit PI
Oh everybody hates him right now yeah he
was like really hated Ram so he proposed
the end to net neutrality he wants
internet to go back to being title one
service and so throughout the whole
summer the agency that was flooded with
over 20 million comments urging them to
preserve net neutrality but a vote will
be held on December 14th by the FCC
members with to see whether or not we'll
still keep it or I'll be gone I just saw
this MIMO for that guy and it's a slow
transition from a Dookie to his face so
for people who are for net neutrality
what's like the what's it's companies
people are for Newton net neutrality its
corporations that are for it because
they could charge more money okay no
they're for getting rid of it getting
rid of it who is for getting rid of net
neutrality and what is like the reasons
for mainly cable companies so first I'll
explain why people support man
neutrality and then I'll get into why
people are against it so the people that
support it are typically liberals and so
getting so what they're saying is that
getting rid of net neutrality would mean
that ISPs Internet service providers
like Comcast Verizon AT&T they will have
free rein to throttle speeds block
websites and carve up the internet into
a slow slow and fast links so they'll
get to be able to to pick and choose
which sites you can access so it
wouldn't be like a free open space
anymore and so they're saying that the
net neutrality rules are set in place
for a reason because is peas have been
previously guilty of attempting to do
all these things which is like block and
all that but that's been illegal mmm
it's been illegal when they try to do
that no it's cuz it was open previously
the when it was a title one they were
doing that and so now that because now
it is classified as a title two they
can't get away with that it's illegal to
do things like that like blocking
certain websites or like favoring
certain companies like for example 18 oh
okay okay I got
I got you man yeah it's like for example
agency had previously tried to block
Apple users from accessing FaceTime so
things like that cuz Bart's been
swatting that [ __ ] fly and now
David's trying to swatting that damn fly
we're trying to have this serious damn
conversation you [ __ ] fly get away
the fruit fly Suzie yes yes we're trying
to learn about serious [ __ ] right now
about net neutrality in there [ __ ]
flies so did you say ATT try to block
absolutely oh these timers yeah I have
these tried to block Apple users from
using FaceTime and things like that like
that's just not fair right
and so all the people that support net
neutrality they don't like the idea that
ISPs would be allowed to plunder the
internet Oh kind of like with cable
right now how you can buy like basic
cable and we would be buying like basic
internet or basic internet speeds if
this would be gone right so then the
internet providers would have the
opportunity at that point to bundle up
certain certain websites and stuff like
this this is one example so for example
here if you want to access Google or any
of these things you have to pay an extra
500 I say if you want to access certain
websites you're not to buy that
particular bus so it's like cable we're
like that one cord that plugs into your
house already offers like thousands of
channels but they want to be able to
charge you more so they're just telling
you it's gonna be twenty bucks a month
but if you want those channels it's
another five dollars another five
dollars but it's like but all those
channels already coming through this
core
that's why a lot of people are heavily
against this because I don't want to pay
extra just cuz I want to watch YouTube
so that's people supporting it and those
money hungry [ __ ] but it's so
smart you know it it's it's also whack
too because like cable companies there's
only like one or two choices because you
know they have each region and it's kind
of like all divided and [ __ ] so and so
also they're also saying supporters are
saying that Internet has become a
necessity in our modern lives and they
believe that allowing corporations who
mainly care about profits to control the
internet would be
unfair yeah [ __ ] that I don't like I
don't like what I saw I know anything
that makes me pay more I don't like no
removing that neutrality opens the door
for censorship and so and then you could
also like block competition and just
sound like China to me yeah and the
biggest part that pisses me off is I
feel that my porn streaming is gonna be
threatened by this thing yeah that's my
biggest fear is no more free porn
yeah no you're an extra I don't like so
much more crime in the streets it's not
you have all these dudes they're all
pent up so when it was proposal it was a
reason why they proposed it like is it
like oh we only have this much in the
bank and you know because we're like
filtering and streaming so much now that
all this Bank is not that it works that
way but you know this reserve whatever
we're running dry it's not like I just
bandwidth okay well I mean but what was
the reason do we know why he proposed it
oh gee yes he proposed it back to one
yeah well it's because okay so then I'll
go into people who support mentality so
people that oppose they argue that they
don't need government-run internet right
that they the companies can just make
their own decisions so it wouldn't be in
the hands of the government be in your
hands with the companies and their is so
supporter or the opposers are saying
that you could just let the market
decide what they want so for example of
a gamer wants to pay a little extra to
have extra fast speeds for the necessity
of the gaming then he can do that and we
don't all have to be on the same level
they're also saying that the internet
was fine before 2015 and they'll be fine
after the repeal and that net neutrality
will still be upheld by a competitive
market pressure from the media and the
watchful eye of the FTC because as of
right now the FCC they're the ones that
are controlling the whole net neutrality
thing but then if it goes back to title
1 then the FTC will be controlling it
instead of the FCC which then will give
more Liberty to companies to do whatever
they want and so no one wants broadband
providers blocking or throttling traffic
and I Spees have made legally
enforceable promise
is to not do these things that's what
they're saying but the FTC has broad
powers to protect consumers from harmful
or deceptive practices so once the FTC
takes over again then they're saying you
know like we're not gonna let these bad
things happen that the companies are
doing but the things like people the
reason why people are against the FTC
having control again is because they're
really slow to really prevent anything
they don't do anything until something's
happening like the whole 18c thing
that's like if you fart and then you fan
it away yeah you should you should have
[ __ ] went over there and farted but
you fart and then you [ __ ] back yeah
I tell you nobody likes that you can't
fart like that yeah but that's the FTC
though the FTC's FTC FTC is letting the
FCC fart and then they're Fanning it
away but that doesn't help because
people still smell the fart right the
bomb in the middle all right FTC no I
throw I throw the fart out like a curve
ball the opposers that because you want
to start with me right now David no I
just really wanted to make that joke
cause it just popped in my head I throw
it into the Astro flat yeah and so
opposers are also saying that true net
neutrality can never be achieved anyways
because there's multiple factors
affecting delivery speeds and there's
regulations that don't ensure equality
if you want faster cable just get
[ __ ] fibre optics or some three t2 t1
Terminator one what's wrong with the
internet right now is what these
opposers are saying is that taxes and
regulations under Title 2 make it harder
for smaller Internet service providers
to compete people don't have the choice
for faster speeds on website they
actually prefer to use or that they use
more often going back to that gamer
example and then they also this is
employee if this is in play right like
let's say you have you you buy the
YouTube one then all your bandwidth will
be maximized for YouTube in YouTube will
be hella fast for you compared to that's
what they're trying to say I see but
there's negatives that can potentially
happen to censorship I mean it's fine
the way it is right
I like it there's no except for my [ __ ]
keeps cut not on why like one example
from this reporter who writes for The
Washington Post she said quote to use
one of those dreaded analogies if you
are constantly driving huge trucks full
of big deliveries of corn ography that's
a along a road why shouldn't you have to
pay more for the roads upkeep so they're
saying like why shouldn't you be charged
a little more for using services that
take up a ton of bandwidth like YouTube
and porn I can see both sides so right
now people that are trying to save net
neutrality what they can do is they can
email or directly call your
representative your representatives in
Congress to stop the FCC can we just
meet in the middle like can one person
say hey how about the bandwidth do this
one this is what we're really worried
about it goes okay as long as you don't
block my part okay we can go like why
can't they just figure that old man
watching porn oh people can watch porn -
I see poor boards like [ __ ] grandma
[ __ ] I don't want you watch the weird
I don't want to trust me I don't want to
watch it I don't want to watch I have to
stop just clicking [ __ ] that's what
happened when I thought it was two
pretty girls I clicked it and you porn
roulette dude you can't do can know
what's in that chamber dude I saw this
one where there's a girl with a strap-on
and I thought another girl is gonna come
in the room but it was another guy that
came in the room and she gave it to him
and I was like why did not just have she
gave it to him give it to me because
there are ladies too cuz me personally I
I like the way things are now
but what if this yeah so the way I like
the way things are not - I agree but
also like listening to their viewpoints
let's say the reason why what's the
speed of internet you have at your house
the fastest one possible so you got the
fastest one we do to rights and I let's
say you get the hundred megabytes a
second and you're paying a hundred bucks
a month for that but what if the reason
you're painful
that is because there's a ton of people
in an entire area that are going on
sites that you don't ever go on and
that's it's hogging up all the bandwidth
so you're paying a hundred bucks a month
to technically get only ten megabytes a
second when if you could just pay ten
bucks a month on the other one because
now you're never gonna go to the sites
that your whole block is going on you
know what I mean like like cuz we have
the same thing where we have a hundred
megabytes a second and sometimes when I
go on a site it's still slow as [ __ ] and
I'm like wait how do we upgrade our
internet and get so [ __ ] slow and
it's because you're sharing that entire
battle it's just like how you're sharing
the water line with their yeah with all
the houses is cuz and everyone might be
taking a shower at the same time but if
I have my own streamline thing I only
want to go youtube or this or whatever
then maybe it can lower the price down
to ten bucks and now the the sites that
I go on daily I can go on hella fast too
is like we can't control what the
Internet service providers would be
controlling which is like what if we
bundle that weird right or not even that
but what if they're just like you can't
access our competitor like you can't
even look at their website early it's
like hindering you it's like yeah
they're China so let's say like Time
Warner is like well we got YouTube and
then now Charter is like we got Facebook
so now you you're like oh [ __ ] what do I
do I'm stuck in the middle so you gotta
get both so that's the [ __ ] yeah I
tell you this just be on my phone I mean
do you guys did you guys see a
difference or 2015 and after 2015 you
with your internet what do you mean
that's when that neutrality was set in
right in 2015 that's when it became
titled - you know what I like I like
Korea - it's free and as fast as [ __ ]
you got Wi-Fi everywhere yeah you could
be on the [ __ ] Street and get Wi-Fi
and it's so strong but that's because
they made their country internet ready
since 1990 or something they already
prepping for the future
how come [ __ ] Ajit is the trying to
propose some [ __ ] like that that is name
ID yeah I think is because the u.s. is
like a order and it's hard because I
often since they haven't had everything
built in yet they
fiber but we don't get that I'll tell
you this I don't know [ __ ] I do like the
way it is now no actually nothing wrong
with the way doesn't know if you're like
it the way it is now than congressman to
like not vote against who's that
congressman I don't know it might be a
congresswoman aren't him alone
our team alone jill brown and
Condoleezza Rice no no these are eyes on
me
yeah but if you to get rid of mentality
just sit back and kick it no I think I
like net neutrality
[Music]